in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Dave
and Holly are with us hey guys how are
you hey welcome welcome
and here to do your debt-free scream
yeah where do you guys live Fort Hood
Texas oh my goodness wow it's a bit of a
travel over here well thanks for coming
all the way to Nashville yeah and the
kids are with you what are their names
and ages well this is Keegan he's 15 Ava
she's 12 and Jackson is 8 all right very
cool I'm glad they came along so how
much dad have you guys paid off well
three hundred and sixty thousand dollars
whoa
and how long did that take 41 months
okay and household income is yeah yeah
we started about 120 and midway through
the process for about 170 and we just
ended closer down to 250 whoa what do
you guys do for a living
Holly is an Army nurse and I'm a nurse
anesthetist oh wow there you go okay so
the 360 might have I was gonna say
mortgage but now that I hear nurse
anesthetist I might say student loans
actually no I was army trained so I
actually was able to avoid the student
loans Oh for me and this is very good
yeah very good so this was your house it
was a whole lot of everything sir we had
actually sold a townhome and that was
actually a total of a hundred and eighty
six thousand of the debt but it actually
was a total about how much I'm forty
seven thousand for the school loans
about sixty thousand believe it or not
for credit card and about forty-eight
forty-nine for vehicles RV you guys were
normal yeah we were totally not a little
bit of everything good arrests included
Wow everything so that is very dramatic
in 41 months so 200 of it 180 of it was
the sale of the townhome but you still
got another 180 or so that you guys
catch flowed in three years basically a
little over three years
that's pretty stinkin incredible that's
amazing so tell me what happened tell me
about the store the story what happened
41 months ago that started this well
Dave and I had first met in 2011 and we
got married and actually we had been
together actually for ten months and
didn't even we lived in two separate
households being military she was at
Fort Sam Houston I was at Fort Hood
separated because of our jobs gotcha
so we had two separate bank accounts I
was taking care of my stuff he was
taking care of his and we had no idea
what each person had as far as debt and
we had a conversation one day and he was
telling me he's very stressed out and
when I found out what the total was
altogether I would just floored me I
just had no idea so I was like wow we
really need to take care of this and
he's like well you're really serious and
I said absolutely
and he gave me your book and I was
something I'd been looking for for years
and I think he can actually kind of
regretted it in the beginning
I won't crazy with it I was gizelle
intense and I don't think that's what he
was looking for I love it yes we
combined everything we you know acted as
a married couple and just we we took
care of everything I love it
congratulations so what was the the the
wildest weirdest craziest thing you did
to get out of debt well I think there's
a lot of little things it was lifestyle
change I quit you know going to the gym
I quit you know doing all those girly
things getting my nails done and my hair
done but I think Dave had the you know
did the biggest sacrifice which was
driving the ex's car for the five years
oh when we were separated too because of
our jobs I actually lived in a small
little travel trailer at Fort Hood while
I was actually tending anesthesia
training well she was I didn't in our
apartment in San Antonio so that was
interesting having to walk like a
hundred yards every day if you want to
use the restroom or the shower that's
real that can get cold yeah amazing but
now here you are with this incredible
income a proven track record of working
together yes and you can conquer
anything and you don't any payments
that's right Wow it's amazing it's a
very cool place to be because you're
making Bank now this is cool
very cool and you deserve every bit of
it congratulations so what do you guys
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is honestly I think it's number one
being on the same page with your partner
you have to know you know that you guys
are both you know on line with each
other it's having that written budget
and it's spending with cash
you know I overspend every single time
when I use my debit card you know I
really do need to stick to that budget
and have cash in hand so I think those
are the keys
communication is a really big thing if
you're not communicating well you're not
gonna be able to you know discuss it
with your partner and this could
actually become a something block in
marriages as well we found you know I
caused some consternation with us we
want to work through it and somehow oh
we call them Tennessee Tennessee we call
it fighting that's awesome
so how long ago did you finish your
nurse anesthetist training and leave the
military
I finished my nurse anesthetist training
in 2012 late 2012 but I was still an
active army officer until this past
summer Oh
so I really wasn't reaping they were you
guys not you you were still separated by
location till summer no sir by 2013 we
actually moved in together okay her
orders brought her to Fort Hood and we
were able to oh okay yeah they helped
out quite a bit when we're actually able
to be in one household instead of having
to and actually start really knocking
things out that's when we saw our
greatest change oh yeah that changes
everything in so many fronts yeah well
Dave and Holly one of the things that I
you know speaking to people all over the
country about this kind of thing you've
mentioned communication and when you
guys I'm sure you had some heated
conversations which you just talked
about and had some conversations that
went really well what are some of the
dynamics of those conversations that
made the good ones go great and the bad
ones you not go so well what were some
dynamics well I think not wanting to
meet each other in the middle or you
know step in the other person's shoes
and try to have some understanding it
was just us talking at each other and
not trying to understand where the other
person was coming from or not wanting to
you know give up a little bit in order
to you know make things work yeah well
you guys are getting incredibly
inspiring it's so cool that you know one
of the things that focuses your
listening in
that you hopefully you heard this that
there was you know she you know Holly
just said immediately I started doing
some things on my end no more nails then
no more hair those are big sacrifices
for a woman and so you started
sacrificing things are really important
to you and so that's really cool that
you both modeled it well you're asking
the other one to do you were doing
yourself it's pretty cool the numbers
are impressive yes just very very well
done you guys
alright guys Dave and Holly Keegan Ava
and Jackson yeah three hundred and sixty
thousand dollars paid off in 41 months
making 120 up to now making 250 between
them count it down let's hear a debt
free scream I'm ready three two one
love it love it love it well done and
thanks for your service to the country -
absolutely amazing Wow that never gets
old Dave good job you guys
good job hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show I want to write a
song I want to own my own business I
want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
new year's resolution is to make more
money this year so wish